نعم سلماء الجديد حتى الان ان ما صدر عن
وسائل اعلاميه مقربه من من قوات النظام ان
الضربات الامريكيه ما زالت مستمره على
مواقع في محيط منطقه دير الزور بالاضافه
الى مواقع في محيط منطقه البوكمال المواقع
التي تم استهدافها وبحسب مصادرنا هناك
مواقع جديده تم استهدافها في محيط منطقه
عياش بالاضافه الى مواقع في منطقه الهجانه
في محيط البوكمال هذه المواقع التي تم
استهداف ها حديثا بحسب هذه المصادر
المحليه هذه المواقع بحسب مصادرنا تسيطر
عليها قوات النظام بالاضافه الى قوات
مدعومه من قبل ايران ايضا هناك اي ايعاز
بحسب مصادرنا كان هناك ايعاز لهذه القوات
ان كان قوات نظام او القوات المدعومه من
قبل ايران باخلاء المواقع التي التي ت
يتواجدون فيها وهؤلاء المقاتلون توجهوا
الى المناطق السكنيه الى المدن الى وسط
المدن فيين في منطقه الميادين
وغيرها للهرب من هذه الضربات المصادر
المحليه قالت ان هناك صوت لسياره الاسعاف
تنقل لربما القتلى او الجرحى او جراء هذه
الاستهدافات مع ان الاست واكدت هذه
المصادر ان الاستهدافات ما زالت مستمره
على عده مواقع في منطقه البوكمال في منطقه
غرب دير الزور بالاضافه الى منطقه الهجانه
ومناطق عده في محيط منطقه البوكمال هذه
المناطق اي التي تم استهدافها بحسب
المصادر المحليه هناك في تلك المنطقه هذه
المناطق منطقه الميادين ومنطقه البوكال
التي
تعتبر مهمه جدا بالنسبه ل لهذه القوات
قوات نظام بالاضافه الى القوات المدعومه
من قبل ايران لقربها من الحدود العراقيه
بالاضافه الى قربها من القواعد الامريكيه
ان كان في منطقه حقل كونيكو او اي حقل
العمر النفطي بالاضافه الى قاعده التنف
العسكريه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الامريكيه في سوريا اها اذا الضربات كما
ذكرت محمد هي لازالت مستمره وهناك مواقع
اخرى كما فهمت منك يجري استهدافها
الان نعم مازالت الاستهدافات مستمره بحسب
مصادرنا في المنطقه تم استهداف مناطق
جديده هي منطقه عياش بالاضافه منطقه
القائم بالاضافه الى ايضا منطقه الهجنه في
محيط منطقه البك هذه المناطق التي تشارك
السيطره عليها بحسب مصادرنا قوات النظام
بالاضافه الى قوات مدعومه من قبل ايران
هناك حاله استنفار كبيره في تلك المناطق
ان كان في منطقه البوكمال ودير الزور
ومنطقه عياش الهجانه البوكمال كل تلك
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها او تتواجد فيها
قوات مدعومه من قبل ايران هناك حاله
استنفار كبيره واخلاء لمواقع العسكريه في
تلك المناطق التلفزيون السوري قال ان هناك
ان الضربات ما زالت الضربات الامريكيه ما
زالت مستمره وتم استهداف حتى الان 12
موقعا في من من قبل هذه الضربات الامريكيه
المصادر المحليه لم تستطيع تاكيد ان كانت
هذه الاستهدافات من قبل ال طيران او ان
كانت من قبل صواريخ اي بالتزامن مع تواجد
طائرات استطلاع